alors on a on a on à ma carrière qui a
refusé de chanter place des compotes
déguisé en patrick bruel
j'vous le dis et j'ai décidé donc de
prendre un nouveau vigiles voilà avec
moi qui va me protéger j'ai pris
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus costaud de
mokhtar se frotte ajout propose
d'accueillir celui qui va remplacer vos
stars il s'appelle léonard
applaudissements points
[Applaudissements]
donc là
voilà
merci c'est bah merci voilà comme ça lui
il est là et lui fait tous les appuis
que je veux mais cyril on vous a dit
qu'il n'était pas vivant c'était pour
deux fois il a pas chanté 1
mais oui tu inquiétez pas il fera ce
qu'on lui dira si c'est par exemple je
me lavais j'ai envie de te mettre une
tape pas qu'est ce qu'il va faire lui
essaye tu verras parce que là vous allez
on prend l'une bêtement allez on y va